last night we the
rler
even wased up by baby gr he said that
Gap was
so
even speed the gritty a GM is shaking
fornite am a grim is shaking
fortnite yeah
amen welcome everybody today is our
annual traditional Thanksgiving special
you laugh you lose we all bring our our
best videos uh submissions to make all
the wonderful people at this table laugh
if they do laugh then they lose and what
does losing mean Sam why don't you tell
us you get to take a little
bite Thanksgiving dish so we've all
assembled here we've all brought our our
our best videos and who who is
sponsoring this Gathering today
sponsored by gamer what a what a better
way to wash it down then with a
refreshing ice cold cup of gamer sub sup
Nation what's up Nation cheers my dude
cheers
myud Ian is live switching so he's not
here I mean he's here but he's not so
Ian say something for the people at home
I'll be monitoring to make sure if
anybody laughs I'm watching the
one uh official Arbiter and judge is
that right that is correct yes so you
are basically the alpha the Omega the
god the Holy Ghost and the mother Mary
anything else to talk about before we
well there's a slightly new rule this
year oh yeah there is a slightly new
rule by the way there's a lot more here
than we've had gathered in the past
there's 10 of us now I mean it's a big
beautiful Thanksgiving uh family yes yes
it is why but everyone here wasn't here
last year how come there were like
various circumstan
love love didn't live here yet uh Zach
was super sick that's
right I got the Tor from the giant
T year ago
remember one of last uh that was one of
the things that inspired me to go
vegetarian too actually the end you've
been vegetarian since then since the new
year but that was like that was a
turning point the was a big Turning
Point yeah uh and then who else I mean
uh well and Sam has never participated
before she was here but she was just
doing the cooking but we decided to
include her this year yeah worth
mentioning I just I don't know why but I
had two hard-boiled eggs before we
started I was hungry I haven't been
eating people say that when your
stomach's messed up eggs is a good food
they do say that they say that
sure they do eggs is a good food when
you're have a ify stomach no are we sure
we didn't make that up eggs well let's
find out our eggs a good food to eat
when you have
food poisoning you have your pair here
you want maybe that to yeah I don't know
should be Bland low and fat and low and
fiber because fat is harder for the
stomach digest avoid fatty foods foods
that are easier in stomach include
cereal banana egg white I had egg white
and gelatin who eats just straight
powder what kind of [__] monster
wrote that oatmeal plain potatoes rice
crackers toast applesauce okay is good
halfway there egg white okay I think
eggs might help with a cold I'm seeing
if you have a cold eggs help with a cold
really what that I've never heard that's
big egg
Lobby how does eggs help with a coal who
is fing
this McDonald they loaded with protein
which is important nutrient to help your
body when you're fighting an illness so
chicken also is good for fighting the
cold Dam we'll say the chicken noodle
soup or whatever chicken noodle soup I
don't like this
it's too it's not
crunchy it's crunchy or not not crunchy
it's too soft are your eggs
crunchy I don't want to talk about
it anything else so yes Sam is here
she's going to be trying her food for
the first time yes are you nervous I
mean you're the only one that knows what
the hell's in yes I'm scared I tried the
food last year to make sure it was gross
but I I'm not ready to do it on camer
I will throw up I'm glad that you're
here I think that's special got the bins
nearby we've got bins AB said he's
pretty sure he's going to puke today you
have a tradition of you are our resident
puker I am pretty anxious yeah but uh
should be good content if there's one
that you on AB that's going to make him
puke could you guess one yeah which one
should I say yeah you can say you're not
to say what's in it but you can say
which one it is it's going to be garlic
in it well there's two there's one that
has a [__] ton of garlic in it oh the
garlic but I think that Middle Eastern
person garlic got that in my whole life
no it it doesn't make me puke it just
grosses me out oh man my white side good
there there's that one but then there's
also one that I think is just like the
grossest what which dish is that mac and
cheese the mac and cheese do you like
mac and Che mac and cheese I yeah I do
but I'm afraid I won't after this also
it's important noting that I went to the
dentist this morning and had a procedure
D oh no feeling a little loopy I don't
know I they uh they uh swapped out a
crown for me and uh yeah I don't know
they had to cut my gums a little bit so
it was a little painful my gums grew
over the the tooth they gave you a
little like Li cane or whatever yeah a
little something something they give you
some other [__] no that's it
okay you're okay to eat yeah yeah I'm
good you don't have to this is of course
love's first time here this is his very
first Thanksgiving
dinner which is so this is the perfect
introduction uh to Thanksgiving for you
my first ever eating a s
creation and what do you understand of
Thanksgiving love as a foreigner
Turkey right yeah that's all we got
that's it he's an American baby do you
know the tradition the story behind
Thanksgiving I think it's probably
racist right yeah definitely absolutely
as all of our great holidays are deeply
racist frankly basically tap dancing on
the on the Indian burial grounds of uh
the greatest genocide greatest and scope
not in like that it was awesome right
just to be clear genocide of all time I
think the Native American genocide was
number one by far right Dan I I know in
raw numbers perhaps yeah I think it was
the biggest new world ever dude ever
what is that I know what talking holiday
story I holiday story is that when the
settlers arrived in the new world you
mean genocidal freaks SL slave drivers
yeah yeah we love them uh 56 million
indigenous people 56 million God they
they had this whole ass beautiful
country and as I think it was Chris Rock
that said when's the last time you saw
two Native Americans in the same place
at once Jesus all right that's brutal
a little dark for Thanksgiving uh let's
just be real about it you know and but
we let's not to be clear it is not a
holiday commemorating this no at least
not direct no the actual holiday was
that the settlers came they were facing
a horrible their first winter winter and
in truth the settlers that first came
here most of them died just because it
was harsh conditions they didn't know
how to how to uh live on the landum and
the Native Americans who were gracious
and welcoming at the time shared their
fall Harvest with the uh Colonial
settlers and they had a great
Thanksgiving feast after which they Ser
they uh things went them on their way it
was a prank oh my God but we remember
that fine
dinner uh and we' as a high point in
relation and we're thankful yeah some
people call it thanks tanking to
Thanksgiving right thanks I don't yeah
and so you sit so the tradition is you
sit around the table and you say uh what
you're thankful for you know should we
do that God no
please that's my least favorite part of
this yeah jeez it sucks dud so corny all
right so we won't be we won't say what
we're thankful for even though we all
know that I'm so thankful for for all
you guys really so thankful I mean wow
really each and one of you guys really
thankful for you too
you go
ahead I'm I'm thankful for all these
guys too oh thank you Dan thanks Dan
yeah good I'm glad we're on the same
page so I'm say the most thankful yeah
all right that's why are you doing it
for him that's for me it it came up
during then okay yeah and I'm also of
course thankful for everyone at home
especially those who open your
wallet big and wide and support this
show uh because let's be honest you know
it's it's not easy being a truth teller
it's not easy going out live to the
world and opening cracking your head and
heart open like an egg and then burping
it out those egg shows right right and
so no but on a serious note I'm so very
thankful for all the audience members
everybody uh not specifically the ones
that pay for memberships but also them
them a lot and everybody else as well
and the broke boys even the broke boys
we love and the Broke Girls and the
Broke Girls
and
[Applause]
and we love you if you're broke we love
you you know I mean listen just don't
buy a coffee it's only $5 a month I'm
kid don't get I'm doing the whole uh
broke Boy [__] avocado yeah I mean maybe
if you just skipped an to you could
afford membership just
endure just endure just endure you
endure excuse me yeah all right thank
you no I love you guys despite your uh
socioeconomical status thank you all
right should we begin yes please all
right so um I people were instructed to
bring three videos three three or four
three or four now I did it a little
differently I know that there's a lot of
people at this table did we explain the
new rule no we started to what's the new
rule rule professional is that if you as
a presenter fail to make anybody laugh
then you are the one that eats makes
sense somebody always loses and that's
our guarantee to you guys at home yep
yep um and that'll be a one-time penalty
paid up at the end of the round right
because if people are showing four
videos it's a lot of you know hubub
but with 10 people I mean you really
messed up you know if you can't make one
person laugh but okay so I'm gonna go
first and then we're going to rotate
through we should maybe uh before we
start your first round present our first
dish go ahead up to
Sam um as you're setting it up I'll
continue to to talk because I wanted to
say that
um most people people are instructed to
bring three or four now I did things a
little differently I know there's a lot
of people at this table and uh in the
interest of you know keeping things
moving I have one video but this video I
made
myself last year I made one that hit
pretty hard and I'm feeling confident
that this one video entry is all it's
going to take wow uh that's confidence
very confident that last year you had
the Jay Leno video right that hit hard
you know I I lay I wasn't here for that
but when I did see that for the first
time I lay in bed sometimes thinking
about that you do oh that's so nice just
wow wow thank you wow I appreciate that
all right so I have a shot of the first
dish here
okay it looks nice oh god what the
[__] a pumpkin pie Sam you want to get
on the
mic this is a pumpkin pie corn dog yes
the the corn dogs are veget
vegetarian there's more uh ingredients
in there we should hold off and let
people try and guess at the end so it's
just a pumpkin pie this is a pumpkin pie
that looks very good yeah thank
you
you that looks
appetizing right who's excited to try
that yeah all right here we go guys this
is my one entry all right my Magnus Opus
Magnum
opius here it is here it goes
baby I brought out the big bunk the big
guns for you Dan this one it's the Baba
buy oh no go ahead get your Giggles out
now all right here we
[Music]
go Baba bu Baba bu Baba
bua bua
Bo just stand okay I'll take definely
the damn
kill
yeaha
bua it's just like 10 minutes of this
everyone break damn it that's it wow
okay all right you know
I I was frankly I was so exhausted
yesterday I just wanted to put something
together and I slept 12 hours last night
w wow yeah like a bear so who who got
got I left cam Z left and thank you guys
thank you everybody I was figh did you
spot anyone else you want to call out
Ian those were the those were the four I
thought I was going to do it man I thank
you guys for laughing I appreciate that
I mean it was engineer to get Dan I was
going to be able to get through the Baba
buy but no no of course of course you're
going to make it through the Baba Bo are
we counting like a smile too or I think
you have to Exhale you have to like yeah
okay a smile is okay we don't have to
eat this whole slice right just just a
bite I
imagine why is there chunks in there
dude why do you like
lasagna does that mean they have to try
the hot dog cuz that's like so much
happening my
to well I don't have to eat it so I
guess I'm okay all right you're safe
dude I am not laughing today I am not
eating any of this [__] [__] I can't
do it I'm sick smells like pizza I'm
worried cuz that was tough that was
really hard for me not to laugh I was
about to
crack I do love corn dos I hate this all
right cam is going for a really Hardy
bite well I'm not going to eat that
whole thing I think you're smart though
to go for mainly the corn doll cuz how
bad could that be I'm trying to get a
little bit of everything in there so cam
go
ahead just a little the maiden's
bite honestly not terrible really eat
the whole thing
okay busing I wouldn't say busing but
it's not terrible it smells like pizza
Dan is not happy about it not terrible I
me I know there's worse to come for sure
I agree Zach is not pleasurable though
oh it's starting to get is there a
little Spice in there a little kick
there is uh Cayenne there's cayenne
pepper in it but there's also Anis which
is black licorice I was about to
say that's an go ahead what do we have
pumpkin pie crust veggie corn dog anise
and cayenne pepper and cayenne pepper
chunks though is that the anus the brown
chunks the brown chunk that's the an
that's the anus chunk anus that's why I
always with a wet wipe anus it's a um a
spice it tastes like licorice why does
it smell like pizza I have no idea
that's really weird that's that's only
you about how hot that supposed to be
all right so uh very good I feel great I
will continue I will not I will not eat
anything today okay famous last words
this is cranberry
sauce that ain't cranberry sauce hold
looks like the devil cranber crry sauce
that is not cranberry sauce it's a weird
shaped cranberry oh God long long
cranberry some long berries some
dingleberries some dag berries dags all
right Dan yeah uh here we go look like
shrimps yeah this is the one I will
not oh that's so foul why would you ew
why would
you I'll tell you what's in it soon soon
you'll know all right so try like all
these I I kind of had people in mind um
I I unlike Ethan I know you're going to
do the tractor one bro no no no I didn't
edit any this year actually but that's
the thing I targeted them towards
specific people this one I kind of think
love might
enjoy well I'm not going to laugh
because I will not eat this dish you're
not going to eat that dish hell no
better not laugh then all right well
eyes up let's see let's see how that
goes let me make sure it's turned nice
and loud so we can hear
him
[Music]
[Applause]
is this a
cover
rights
[Music]
like now no takers okay I've actually
seen that video I've seen that too yeah
oh not fair you sent this to me before
did I
yeah is it aist or is this is a aist
video or ableist video
Dan [__] Jam I I remember one of the
top comments on that video was bro
sounds like he's taking poison
damage that's fun that's a good one uh
well shoot um that was funny I'm just
terrified of that I understand that's uh
there's a lot uh on the line here this
think is one of the more mild ones
person well did you think the last one
was gross cuz they had no problem with
it they crushed um I did think that was
was more mild yeah okay homie shredded
though I mean shouts out to him right is
there lore to that video like uh I don't
think so I think there's just been a a
spree of uh older guitar players like
that one video you sent me you you know
Uncle te yeah yeah yeah he's awesome
they're out there now they're they're
out there they're out there getting
their voice out um all right so this
next one uh I always try and come to
this with at least one world record
video because you guys know I love those
world record videos absolutely this is
one of the most impressive I've seen um
oh my goodness [__] eh what theine
board broken between legs from a single
jump no
way wait why did that why is that a
thing what what the
[__] the [__] bro don't come out here
and flex you didn't do anything you just
got dropped from the top of a building
on his nuts
dude why is that a [__] thing I don't
know how was that a record that's like
the 50th time I've seen that video and
I'm crying oh I love it so an
idiot so I got quite a few on that one
right who who even set that up for him
like a whole serious set up should we
should we go to the end and then
everyone I guess just remember every if
you laugh I'll keep track that was cam
Ela Ethan and Zach on that one but then
if you laugh again is there what's the
punishment Ian or you just [__] no I
think you'd have to take another bite I
think right yeah yeah or can you just
enjoy the rest of the round
sa it I think you should maybe be able
to just cut loose for the rest of the
round and that would make it harder for
the others
exactly after going we're Cutting Loose
all right Cut Loose everybody have fun
laugh at the top of your
lung all right uh why is that a
why dumb that's unbelievable Guinness
World Records is out of control they
needed was that an official one it
looked like it homies got nuts of Steel
Man somebody invested some money yeah
serious setup there can we watch that
one more time ninja war not not as an AR
official capacity just to
appreciate wait so it says something on
the sign in the background
maybe yeah it's the logo is in the
homie's out
[Music]
man bro his he a having kids after
that oh what a [__] he's got sawdust
in his beard that was a detail I forgot
to point out the first time he when he
finally gets up and starts yelling his
voice is all high pitched in a cartoon
right I did notice that is crazy
than oh my God it's so good man all
right next up I got two more um
that's oh yeah um you all know Cory
Felman of course right great goon I
don't know well he's uh I don't know if
you're familiar with his music career um
he's uh got famously I think one of the
lowest rated albums of all time he put
out by who he was a just across the
board Anthony Fant just widely hated
widely hated just for reference me and
cam have a whole Cory Feldman uh we're
Feld heads we f yeah know that Cam's
seen this one already but he already
laughed so he's not my target here so
let me know what you think this song's
Awesome song
[Music]
DRS that
was wait one more time it's only
seconds
M you know what he literally R stepped
on a rake and hit himself in the face
him
one idiot all right I think I got Olivia
with that one you did add one more so
who hasn't left Sam uh Sam Lena Love and
ab and Lena you guys are not all right I
got one more shot one more shot I don't
think I laugh at all you don't think
you'll ever laugh bro you gotta laugh I
got so much [__] last year for not
laughing just don't I would laugh if I
could Love's got that
Hawkman all right this is my final video
all right I don't know if you guys have
ever seen the editing styles of Indian
soap
operas uh I think I actually had a
different one last year if I remember
but the [__]
rolles wait for
real
what no
way [__]
way
I oh that's so
funny that was you didn't you didn't
edit that Indian uh drama no that was
already like that but then I because the
editing was already so insane I figured
I'd incor aesome never seen that my
favorite video in there so that's it
that was fun that's
it all right everybody let's dig in I'm
not eating the shrimp I don't eat shrimp
it's not Kosher that's I'm not eating
the [__] shrimp I don't I never eat
shrimp no I never eat shrimp either it's
not Kosher I did not want to eat that
shrimp so I didn't this looks so [__]
up bro bro you're going to make what are
you going to tell AB to eat pork cuz he
laugh crazy so I also don't eat shrimp
but I guess I'll eat some more of this
[__] hot dog [__] the that there'ss
you got this ol Live Well I'll eat the
jello the jello sounds is the jello not
rancid it's got shrimp juice in
it I just can't believe I'll take a bite
of the cranberry is there shrimp in it
yeah I know Dan you can take a bite of
the cranberry there's no shrimp in this
oh that was so n do that and I'm kosher
100%
always me too Ethan this is so
did
you yeah don't no don't you dare love
converted to
Judaism yeah while he was staying with
us yeah that's
true we'll share this one I'm kosher
give me the shrimp yeah give him the
shrimp why is it so jelly is it usually
this gelatin jell I added gelatin oh so
you made it even gnarlier
God what's that Chunk in there
you can't oh shrimp texture it looks
like a sheto it smells so strong yeah I
have this oh my God it's garlicky huh
this guy says he's from Boston and he
can't eat shellfish red I know you
believe this guy SM smell it I smell it
bring unbelievable you want me to just
take a bite of the shrimp actually kind
of like the smell sorry it's good for
you I'll [__] [__] it I I mean I'll yeah
get in there l oh love I don't want to
laugh but I'll honestly kind of no
that's too big a bite girl I don't want
to eat the shrimp what this is the jelly
kind of good actually love says the
jelly is good
oh oh
come all right I'm going to take a bite
of the jelly I didn't even bite give me
the trash can just the smell aot give me
trash the trash can oh W give me the
trash can what little bag of here dude
B [__]
you
wow oh no bag can thanks for holding
back on that that was very impressive
right cheers let's go together Cheers
Cheers the [__]
dude I
hate I just hate everything about
this well damn disgusting oh [__] is
that bad huh I don't want that in my
body I can get some more I ain't going
to lie I don't know oh [__]
off there's lots of garlic in it right
yeah garlic powder garlic did you hit
the garlic that's in the jar right ew
dude yeah it's like like disgusting burp
yeah it's
a it tastes the garlic is lingering it's
a cherry Jell-O cocktail shrimp and and
garlic that's devastating cuz I love
Cherry Jello-O that was everything I
hate the garlic in the jell is so vile
it's so lasting it's lingering like a
[__] swamp in my mouth you know who's
the real loser here is Sam and Ian
because their kitchen must [__] re
yeah it's bad really bad you
okay you want toell I'm good are you
hungry I'm just being a [__] Sam you
did beautiful work with the sauce oh
dude that was so B yeah it was bad but
um well done everyone down in that I
guess uh cam you're up next so we just
oh yeah baby it's gamer sub Nation let's
give up give it up for Thanksgiving
gamer sub Army rise up right now what
better way to kick back some turkey some
stuffin some yams then with a highly
charged sip of that gamer sub is charged
with caffeine with vitamins with
electrolytes to energize and hydrate you
to maximum potential lightning bolt
sound can you do that
nice that's it that's why I love gamer
Subs I'll tell you why first of all it
tastes great we have our own flavor
Sigma brain it's spicy Margarita
flavor there's no sugar it tastes great
it's energizing this is why I like it I
don't necessarily always like to drink
caffeine or coffee I mean because it's
super acidic you can get your caffeine
in this delicious drink while also
getting hydrated and your mouth doesn't
become coated in like brown sludge you
know I mean let's be real drinking
coffee [__] your mouth up and your
breath it's
gross so when you sip this you get the
energy you get the hydration you get the
caffeine and there's no sugar so if
you're like hooked on sugary drinks
gamer Subs can really change it around
for you no calories no sweetener and
that's what I love about gamer Subs um
there's also a caffeine free version if
you just want to tast the beverage um
they've got all kinds of great deals
going on here today Gamers sub is
launching the new waifu cup heaven in
hell with matching hoodies and
sweatpants as well as a side bag I'd
show you guys but I think these photos
might be too graphic they're I genuinely
just stacked the they're stacked you can
use your imagination you know but
they're also running deals
um if you spend a certain amount you get
items for free and yes the deals do sack
spend 30 bucks get a free scker pack 50
get a free set of gaming sleeves 75 free
shirt 100 free Guardian Angel Wu jug 150
a free sweater and you get all of that
they all stack up so they are just
giving it away
folks but yeah if you want to support
the show go over to um
to gamer STS and try the uh exclusive H
flavor Sigma brain and get 10% off your
order for that or any other flavor when
you go to gamersupps.gg and use the code
H3 to get 10% off your order that's
Gamers
subs. use the code H3 and get 10% off
your order thank you so much the gamer
Subs sponsoring us we love you please
consider supporting them and thank you
so much
Cam I am scared of your videos I'm you
might give me cuz I know I know I don't
know we'll see
got we'll see up God what what the [__]
is
that e dude get that [__] out of my
[Music]
face girl you put that on the table
garbage water what the [__] is that
literally that's literally garbage
disposal Sam why did you make
that wait I want to you'll be fine
you'll be fine cotton candy what is that
what's the red
stain you'll know what you'll know what
the red stain is
lovely no I
wish compar to whatever it is you okay
why do we do this why do we do it for
the people people all right let's go
ahead um must be really bad for my first
video here um Thanksgiving if you guys
didn't know love it's about about you
know settlers leaving England so I
figured I'd do a little uh homage to our
brothers and sisters across the pond
very good this is the united we love
them we love the
UK God bless I'm walking for me grandson
I'm going to pick any random stranger
house do a ho I'm in the mood think I'll
do this one
guys there's a window
here this Five Nights at Freddy's the
new one
[Applause]
right you [__] little I've just been
on that [__] motor way stress the
[__] I about to smash can of my usual
pink chin I said the Menace is
rolling I can only have two of these cuz
I got to go Bible bashing church
tonight see praise the
Lord I am [__] fuming mega mega
[__] fuming [__] Li breaking down
on a [__] time and no bo I'm [__]
angry [__] getting soaking wet hey
every [__] day I F out with
[Music]
it was so good that was really was happy
laugh holy
[__] yeah I don't know I just think it's
funny I don't know I yeah that's how it
works and you're the first girl of a
wild hog girl oh yeah she's been blowing
up wait those were so fun I just love
that you know we we recognized England
as the cradle of civilization and the
birth place of Civility and uh it also
where where it dies I guess too and we
love him for that we love him for that
who did I get with
that love
Z I was so think of our unborn child ELO
he doesn't need that food man don't
laugh for him he's not hungry bro he's
not why is it SL dishing it up uh I
don't know oh it doesn't oh yeah it does
slide around a little bit as one solid
tell me if there's shrimp in there no
this is it's all it's all vegetarian can
you tell me what's in there now I have
to oh you need you need gravy we not
waiting I smell it maybe we should wait
right oh are don't you guys want to wait
oh okay I can here I'll I'll do a Lo
[Music]
yeah that y this is the iconic I know
what this is this is the peppermint
mashed potatoes that God I hope not I
don't smell no Peppermint destroyed the
destroyed just the first
year Dan's always complaining about that
that one I I haven't forgotten about it
scarred me like for real well this wow
look at that M nice consistency looks
good oh what is this I'm literally going
to [__] like how is love like on the
one hand the most freaky eater and on
the other hand also like downward
everything oh I like potatoes and
peppermints peppermint
oh boy what is it Sam all right we'll
get to it at the end of the round though
all right I'm not eating that [__]
please Ethan [__] keep it together
you're how many videos you got you
didn't laugh how many videos you got I
did not laugh cuz that was tough for me
to get through all right boy W I made it
we'll see okay this one damn uh as we
know uh the settlers went from England
to New England so I want to do a little
homage to my favorite video here of uh
two guys from New
England I don't finding a sunfish I
don't know what this is but Jay says
it's a [__] big sea turtle oh it's a
baby wheel it's a baby [__] wheel
man the shaking kid we're not going to
be able to get him out oh man oh [__] I
got to shut this off right now all right
wow are they for real oh
yeah they killed that poor fish though I
guess so I don't know I mean I didn't
see the end there but I'm pretty sure
that thing dead how could you man I know
[__] Jay Foster Jay didn't seem that
into it like whoever was speaking he was
way more enthused about whole he had a
Silent Bob he been by himself that poor
fish rest in peace that F but did you
get anybody new with that I don't think
so I think I got a nobody got I did not
see any laughs uh AB has been sort of
hiding behind Ethan's head so I can't
proper block love that's I'm sure yeah
I'm sure yeah it's a it's a tough tough
call so I need you guys to keep them in
check all right I'll scoop I'm gonna sit
back okay all right for my final one you
guys know I have a pretty cursed Tik Tok
feed on a on a burner account so this is
just a few selects uh and my friend sent
me a couple of these too um so you know
just just some recent this is my own
type of Boston fishingman right here
right some strange
SEL not the calling all hoes calling all
ho if you're a good-looking girl and you
want to run a train on Northstar please
message below baby
lock put some music ont and
slow be a [__] [__] liar when your
significate other comes home do not
stress them out let them distress do not
be a [__]
[__] that's
awesome is this the real
life is this just fantasy you only lose
when you give up remember this you only
lose when you give up if you don't give
up you will win from the most incredible
positions day four of me spraying dog
medicine on my hands to make the skin on
my hands tougher uh they feel just a
little bit tougher a little
bit that's right guys you're back in the
mix with Chicago's hottest couple Warren
and Grady and tonight we are on location
Burger King on Fullerton Avenue one of
the better Burger Kings in the city um
playing music a little loud you know
obviously we would have preferred to
have done a song of our own but you got
to have a hosle in jail right so my
hustle was I would charge people $20 a
comissary for them to touch my chin
while they were in the shower that's
also how I got the nickname titty chin
you say strange things for change I say
20 bucks 20
bucks
CH even like
this yeah that is not a real no is this
a real [__] La Sheriff
sometimes I just feel like I want to
levitate the problem is the
[Music]
landing that's that made it I made it I
made
it I told you I'm not
eating I'm sick I giggled those were
good oh I I did not Olivia giggle yeah
is that a so Lena and ab you got what
what are what are you guys colluding on
what's the deal here Sam Sam didn't
maybe sedated I got or Sam if anyone
knows what's on the line she's not
laughing everybody bone Apple it is
potatoes buttermilk peppermint extract
crushed candy cane yep [__] you garlic
powder y [__] you pickle juice oh that
the gravy is pickle juice and soy sauce
oh [__] the peppermint I don't know what
it is about a bitter thing at the end of
it just got Ruma I'm telling you guys
Dan doesn't complain about a lot every
time we bring up this episode for months
Dan's like oh I hope there's no more
peppermint potatoes I know Ethan talks
about the pepp potatoes I'm so confused
this is not that bad oh my God you are
so take a bite then show me show me
going back for seconds Olivia has
the that's the phenomenon that is love
somebody needs to study this man it's
not that
bad okay all right put some broccoli
Vietnam right
now I remember I remember those
peppermint [__] mashed potatoes dude
I spit that out all right so um Sam is
next up this is green bean casserole M
classic I love green be it is a
Thanksgiving love this I wonder how you
ruined it you'll love
this okay so there's veggies in here oh
yeah yeah veggies
lots of veggies in there okay are we
ready he doesn't care about the ate
peppermint potatoes with [__] and
shrimp shrimp jizz
yeah oh God forbid one green bean I'm
nervous all right go ahead everybody can
see everyone eyes up eyes on screen eyes
up all right he's up eyes
up I've seen what and his talent is
impressive I mean that's not easy to do
he's good he's real good he's not he's
just I guess it would be impressive if
he would actually eat it instead of just
letting it waterf over his
mouth what a g he's getting a decent
chunk following though or just
treading
wow I think is so powerful he is really
I know that was excellent um did you get
anybody though no hope you like green
bean gas
rule I think there's a lot of cross talk
it's a distraction I I feel like there
shouldn't be any commentary com no
talking sometimes I want to laugh at
people's commentary well I thought that
was maybe would help make it harder I
don't know no commentary uh Ian says
chocolate I love those what do you call
those r
rooch itero oh those are good I like
those little
[__]
okay Dad I am so full Christmas has been
just wonderful grandma just wonderful
can we read what it said don't want to
step don't want to step on the hose here
[Music]
sorry oh come on man grow up
what a
monster that is horrific it said the
text said trying to quietly fart in my
grandma's oxygen tank what a
demon you guys these videos are funny no
it
is I just uh someone dude Sam might be
tasting her own dish here that guy has
that multiple times what do you mean oh
it's just once you're right yeah just
once oh my goodness Sam okay it is just
one so I thought it's the whole turn oh
no what is these little dumplings I had
to eat one yeah yeah okay oh
Patty Hamburg NE and cheese
baby oh
yeah babe it's getting ready to go down
do you hear the
seing
yeah baby slap the cheese on it
baby mil baby get the toes yeah put the
toes on it
baby toast up baby slap the burgers on
the bread baby put it on the toasted
bread baby b let it be running baby let
it be running with it gold them
hamburger baby
cheeseburgers baby look like I'm getting
ready to hurt myself oh like I'm getting
ready to hurt
myself running with hamburger and cheese
oh yeah babe this ready to go
down is that the Kool-Aid man wow I
don't know oh my God I'm that's mon man
Savage it makes me think of Wally PE
yeah I only got Dan yeah imag I was
biting my tongue it is that's exactly
what my feed looks like his voice is
incredible what he does with it is
really phenomenal like that see what he
looks like like the throat singing you
can do Mongolian throat
[Music]
singing get you some yum yum get you
some yum yum get you some extra Cy a
Dan it does I mean it's how else do you
describe that texture it yeah you're
exactly right wait why do I have to eat
it you didn't cuz they didn't laugh dude
Oh I thought it was for the
whole neck no girl CH rules that's what
we said different rules you better eat
can I get Fork yeah my Fork I want this
actual my [__] up I can make it on
maybe on I've never made green being
coll but I'm sure I could do it Sam's
got a recipe for
you all right I got Dan is going in for
nice there it is Dan Happy Thanksgiving
all right cheers Che my my bite's real
big you cooked it so true Sam went for
it well done she's chewing that's a big
bite Dan is grimacing a little bit
Grimace shake and Fort
nighting Dan is Sam is expression so
normal what happened in there what have
you done what happened Sam what is
happening Sam is expression now I really
can't tell there's a lot happening
yeah uh it
is really wanted to swallow and be over
with it my body just like won't let me
green beans cream of mushroom soup
crispy onions caramel soy sauce and raw
onions oh you know what that almost s
almost normal caramel well the caramel
certainly but I like
caramel I don't know about caramel green
beans so wait is it just green bean
casserole with
caramel yeah and soy sauce soy sauce I
feel could fit kind of a yeah
interesting you want to try some no
yourself I
mean I feel I taste the caramel like
after yeah big time it's dessert yeah
should have done this one last AB you
want to try it I'm good thank you
too powerful what can you do no it's I
hate the caramel I hate caramel caramel
is like my least favorite yeah all right
um Olive is up right let's do the
swappers this is
stuffing sure looks pretty good this one
looks the worst e dude really yeah so
far
regurgitated cat something yeah oh God
don't put that in my head so why does
stuff
uh well stuffing is cooked inside the
turkey but dressing is outside the
turkey so it's kind of it's dressing
basically turkey no no bread up to
turkey's ass it's a mixture of like
bread and and cornbread and you'll love
it you'll you'll like it it's good
perhaps what is this people love
it are we ready for the first
I what you got okay the [__] is
that okay I checked it for
[Applause]
CLS wa it's what want it's what want
it's what you
want H 6 in the I just want to rock I
just want to
ah
[Music]
I
got my my
don't you better
choose that's my heart 1 2
[Music]
[Applause]
3 that's my
[Music]
heart
this I want this what I want this what
you
[Music]
want
all right I like his shirt I really
enjoyed that it's V stunning yeah did
did little Uzi vert invent that one
dance where you go like this was that
him or someone else where you go like
what the the the one that kaette does
shuffle the futel Shuffle yeah that's it
yes I think I think he invented it
that's pretty if he didn't he'
definitely like popularized it so yeah
well he has a song that's mad
credentials though I love that move
all right so next who do we get on that
round
miss you almost got me just one he went
it was amazing held that note pretty
powerful TS a r m y am I this way it's
cuz BTS taught me how to love and speak
and be myself we are bulletproof so show
me and I'll show you how we
count
and the description is interesting it
says uh her voice is honestly not that
bad I just wish she was a normal
person BTS wow wow we do love BTS we do
we do we stand stand I would never Li we
we hope them a short and uh uneventful
uh military service absolutely right
yeah they'll be back they'll be back
they won't die in combat right no no I'm
keeping them far away from the front
line they wouldn't put him in the front
line yeah no
way fonie
what what's a girl's name that's Frank
Francine
Belinda Vanessa yes oh that was good by
you
Ursa
jasine oh it's on you Fran
scene FR
Shane Vanessa oh you said
Vanessa you can't do the same I will
[__] knock you can't do the same
that's a rule that's not Fu that is a
rule you said Vanessa earlier he didn't
make up that we didn't agree to that
being a rule it's a
rule Vanessa already been said already
been said that's the rule you can't say
the same name
twice Sally Sally you need to do it
quicker Sally I get it
now
oh sorry I
[Music]
slipped Luke seal
L look look see how Patricia is it a
pain it's a
P Lucille
Lucille Tiffany
bian did you say bian earlier
no
l oh you
filming I was looking myself upside
[Applause]
[Music]
down all right I have one more they look
like a lot of fun
though they're great why are they not I
just really don't want to eat this one
oh yeah this will be the first one I
don't have to eat I thought I made it oh
no I've got one more so wait that means
you're on the line now right I don't
think there was a laugh during that yeah
no she she's got to eat
it you to in fact here can somebody uh
get that ready for a and Sam you can you
can prepare her but she's not
pregnant oh I see listen our unborn
child what is happening he did not laugh
Jesus you she can't e what the [__]
oh my God I got shaky hands and you guys
are all aelous
e are we ready oh oh God all
right oh no come on show a closeup oh
that does smell like Pew we show the
what even
is it looks disgusting no it's not or
dressing yeah you're right what's the
little little water do you want me to
reveal it now we got one more video I
think we one more one more man oh I know
what the [__] let's do
this I can hardly breathe when he's
pumping deep inside I kiss him on his
neck and then he kisses on my buy call
him daddy while I holler man that boy so
damn good
[Music]
[Applause]
looking he he said did they say he's
jump dancing on my busy yeah he did yeah
he did and you didn't like it you didn't
giggle about it I did like it but I'm
not eating that [__] no all right I'm
about to dig in what is this like what
is this this
is sour that Sour Patch watermelon
that's what happens when you cook a
watermelon Sour Patch it's fat a stove
top stuffing mix and
sourkraut oh interesting so
gross sour go El took a good Valiant
bite of it oh my God Olivia's gagging
immediately it's nasty it's
nasty okay's kicking it down [__] yeah
love you guys both kicked it down huh
Sister Sister snatched it the candies
are still pretty good if you just eat
love you are a demon all you are you are
demonic it's my you just Crush one of
those at the end to it's not gray but
what you mean this I got a full one for
you that's what I just that's what you
just oh you took a bite of it not finish
it
there's a full one okay yeah any I
swallowed it okay moving
on well done well done I Haven I haven't
tasted this so it may actually not be
that bad but is there meat in it
okay nice mouth on the
top yeah
it's pretty good nice cheesy looking
exterior there gross are we ready yeah
so okay this is my first video now this
just in police officers in Lancaster
Pennsylvania were asking people to be on
the lookout for a man who robbed a store
and I think yeah I think we do we do
have his descript can we take that let's
take his
description okay okay this is the guy
they're uh they want they wanted people
in Pennsylvania to be out on the lookout
for he's got uh he's got a nose and some
hair that goes like that and he was uh
he was wearing a hat at the time of this
particular particular crime he got kind
of a chin that comes down to a almost a
point stands about 5' 4 in
tall there it is get a good look for
yourself oh and now I'm getting word
that police actually caught this guy
thanks to the sketch no doubt so here's
a picture of the real guy next to the
sketch that led to his arrest where's
the pointy CH it's uncanny
Lisa uh the guy on the left is now
charged with two counts of fat is being
held in the Lancaster jail and I say
give that sketch artist a
rise this wouldn't be so it is quite a
journey because it does look a lot
like it is quite a journey that's
amazing
make laugh until we saw the
actual oh man now this just in police
officers in
Lancaster okay all right let's go round
two so Ela and Dan got got yeah yeah got
me all right dude that is [__]
disgusting e what the jeez what is what
the hell is even happening dude like
curdled just Mac and cheat
then I already don't like mac and
cheese all right okay this one looks
like it's made for Ethan video number
two I'm not
laughing I like where it's going down
first seconds right here second I'm
going to try to reach underneath of this
but right here I feel like I've seen all
back up in the air any pain there when I
push there not
really not yet he said not
[Music]
really feel that I think this chiroprac
can even make hunger FF blush said not
really are you ready not really that
whole finger was over that man's ass
yeah [__] oh my God and then just
putting the pants back on oh so did that
not get any new people then no I'm not
going that
meansa no I have I have one more video
it's not how it works doesn't work
though any video doesn't get any new
people okay you're busted so you're in
fine by me that looks
delici okay all right oh no it's not
last one
yep oh I'm excited L's already laughing
it says no whose grandma is this oh this
is my
this is my second time exclusive here at
Gard park at the cool cat karaoke
Missy's funky white sister is in the
park is it worth it let me work it I put
my thing now flip it and reverse it is
your
he you got a
big find out how hard I got to work yeah
is your this is your this wi I like to
get to know yes I can show
you like told you give me all your
numers so I can phone you you better S
call
me before
come I'm counting it like a vop see my
hips I'm a CHP don't chop see my ass I'm
a lip don't you I lost few pounds in my
whips for you this kind of be to
go to say blah blah blah work it I need
a glass of water boy oh boy it's good to
know Y is it worth it let me work it P
my thing now FP and reverse
it
your if you got a big let me search you
find out how hard I got to work yeah
he's shering in the
yes wait did you write that is that
original is that a
cover dude are you serious like song
she's killing
it she was even singing the reverse part
RSE really well she was cooking on some
hot brought her own sound effects they
do that in the song too yeah the show F
was
why disgusting such a weird detail I did
laugh cuz was hilarious all
right at the end there holy [__] on your
fork Dan is doing a nice Valiant bite
there this one I think might smell the
worst this far you want to try it love
right so you said this might be the
worst one after it oh because oh right
exactly okay um there there wasn't
everyone here eats eggs right there was
an egg not this one go ahead go ahead
dad got it all right this was ah
garbanzo bean pasta wait blue
cheese uh there was caramel an egg and
sharp cheddar oh you can't eat it when
you're well you you can just uh T you
get you can get the The Vibes it's I
don't think B is
p I'm not sure oh we looked this up and
it depends so yeah just play it safe um
I immediately gagged I almost threw up
just now and I spit it out I can't eat
that okay but L how still chewing yeah
no it's bad but you're going to swallow
it huh yeah
wow wow this probably is the
wor probably you I think it did just
give it a shot yeah it like eating mold
right I [__] hate blue cheese go
ahead love honestly for you to try it I
wouldn't be able to eat a single one of
these ingredients alone here listen love
here's what's we you need to understand
you're going to a Thanksgiving dinner
you can't say if put something in front
of you you got to eat it that is true
it's you're being rude right now you got
to eat it you better just Puck her up
and practice it's like in myse expand
your um your palette love I'll put it in
my mouth but that's all I could ever
asked you're about
to you're about to straight up throw up
you got this love I like Let It Be in my
mouth for a sec just let it swallow and
it's good job
love oh oh no come on put your tongue on
it put your tongue on it I sucked it
yeah you're out that's a great sound B I
feel like you don't want to chew it I
feel like I got the jizz noiz you sucked
it and you got the jiz yeah yeah I don't
need I don't you don't need anything but
all that was far in away the worst
one that [__] smell it put get a nice
good
sniff it's bad it's like that
she who eats that [__] I would be sick I
can't do it guys don't be mad at me I
can't do it okay this is sweet potato
sule I don't think this one will be too
painful I think this one will be okay
but that's just me lean on the the uh
the marshmallows this one looks very
normal compared to many of the others
we've seen yeah but what's below the
surface is the question Dad yeah
Ys all right okay uh just start this off
everything is royaltyfree and checked um
thank you thank you and what are you
thankful for this year's
Z that
um I don't know you sold out you were at
the Bold oh yeah uh there's been a lot
of great things
uh I don't know did you get the Rolex
was that last year or this year last
year it's all new it's trash now yeah um
you clean that thing regularly [__] yeah
how do you clean it I take uh some Dawn
soap and a microfiber towel under some
warm water not hot um want to get that
fat scratch you could get it wet fat
scratch yeah oh that's love baby I'm
just kidding he he has insurance on it
either way oh right okay um what am I
thankful for you do yeah how much is the
monthly payment for the $1 a month okay
I mean [__] why not it's not a bad
that's a good I mean yeah um does it
cover theft I'm blessed I have a
beautiful does it cover theft yes what
wow you're up nice L all right beautiful
family um awesome co-workers and I'm
just grateful how often do you clean the
watch once a week once a week every
Sunday I do all my jewelry
nice how long do you spend cleaning the
watch I do shoes and watch wow it's
OCD it's cool though don't you also do
your car every Sunday do my car every
Sunday paint my nails every Sunday wow
oh Sunday's a big day for you day that's
Z's
Day Day the Z day all right Z day all
right so uh got this this this lovely
video right here okay here's what yall
think try to relax your
[Applause]
anus your shoulders
[Laughter]
all right so we just made up a new rule
specifically to Target
AB if there's anybody who hasn't tasted
the food by the end if they haven't
tasted I'm talking literally only about
AB because everyone else has tried it
then the table votes on which one for
that person to
taste this is uh
[__] better make a move and Ian what
about Ian he gets to does he get the
pass you know I'll eat if eat I'll save
him a plate he sits back there like oh I
have to switch like come on come on how
difficult could it be Ian which one are
you
tasting I'll eat anything dude I'm a
garbage can right he'll go with you I'm
Sam's guinea pig I have to eat this [__]
all the time so true he tasted this [__]
already he had to taste all of my f fish
uh last year you are a beast man I'll
never forget you monster ing a whole
piece of
FEA bones you taking bones and cartilage
out of your mouth we should lock arms
Ian with our shaky hands and feed each
other that's nice be a nice moment I
like that idea all right that would be a
nice way to end the episode yeah no
thanks hold on I'll do it I'll do it
this is light work I could eat this
stuff all right it's easy sounds good to
me are we we ready go
ahead video number to from Zack I like
this guy oh my God my favorite fell
[Music]
f
time
oh that was going on for so long is see
for real oh my God yeah is he winking is
that what he's
doing he has his whole
dance I'll say that um his slow
movements are pretty impressive if you
look at his wink too the slow wink it's
not even a full wink he like goes 95% I
notic that little a little SLI he's
still
looking what made that so hard for me is
that looks like an 80s photo of Lena's
dad like that looks just like an 80s
photo of your dad yeah and once I
thought of that that was [__] killing
me man he he works in that little little
store selling nuts or wherever and he
streams it like seven hours of the day
just so he's a nut salesman for I think
it's nuts right and honey I don't know I
mean I'm not exactly sure what's his
good are but I don't know but you're a
fan right big fan big doing all the
mov I know the moves like we didn't
laugh
[__] he imune he's seen too much
anybody I don't think so I had a little
exhale you had an exhale you didn't have
to admit to that I I'll give you the
okay all right one
more oh my god oh oh I know this guy
too that a Mentos oh no
no
no holy
[__] oh yeah wait is that
real
no no way one more is it a that real
wait play that
again is this fetish content it has to
be got to be we know who would love this
Colleen's dad
absolutely inflation porn oh yeah dude
no
way thank you Cameron
no way I'm more just shocked yeah that
was crazy he he does a lot of this is
like feeding stuff he's so brave oh he's
so bra bra a warrior he's a fetish
Warrior I do have one more cuz my videos
are short if I'm allowed yeah yeah that
was just three right you can do four now
this one just kind of uh amazed me
okay like his the gloss on his lips
already yeah oh
okay okay that's
disgusting what are you doing
man the hell that was a weird entry that
was good
got that was strong
dude us play it again yeah and just
stare Encore Encore what's a message
there
is he trying to spin on his
phone
camera missed that
one think he farts there this the ending
is my favorite when he looks down and
tries to end
it very good very you're laughing
yeah the commentary got
her uh yeah all right so who did I goton
you got Cam and uh I think you got El I
hate to say it and yourself and then you
have to do it yourself yeah so what do
we got here s uh
Samantha why you remove yeah for
laughing cam can't eat the
marshmallows wait why can't are
you thanks for laughing oh is there
gelatin in marshmallows gelatin from
animal I didn't know
that is there non-gelatin marshmallows
yeah there are hell marshmallows oh
really what are they called there's hell
marshmallows without
gelatin in case like you had uh cuz they
pork gelatin oh there's oh I didn't know
it was
pork skeleton's pork it's not
necessarily pork it's deated uh I don't
know yeah no it just has to be Halal
because yeah it comes from animals I
always Pig I see I see I see okay this
is sweet potato buttermilk cinnamon
pepper taco seasoning and
marshmallows it's probably going to be I
was trying to make it
spicy it smells really no Greek yogurt
right no Greek yogurt I promise shout
out to the Tor wa wait so I got a little
bit of that and a little bit of yeah
should I hit it hit it D I hit
it cam is chewing he's having a hard
time with this for sure Zach is having a
hard time ela's definitely grimacing
this is too much going on at once what's
the actual there's garlic in there isn't
there uh no
oh the tacos season everyone's bailing
Zach is is it
spicy went for a huge
bite oh my
God hold on love is took a huge bite are
you going to be able to eat that yeah oh
yeah mhm and then how do you rate that I
think it's pretty good what what is the
the orange stuff sweet potato sweet
potato oh it's a vegetable
it is a vegetable pretty
good I love that the ones were like
gross obviously but I could hold it
together this is he eat this there's so
much try sweet potato yeah well that's
one of the thing I like yeah yeah yeah
yeah
we Trader Joe's also has a great sweet
potato uh you put in the uh how was that
you good it like loves that I don't
think it was the worst one but it was
pretty bad it's just like taco seasoning
is like it's just a bunch of random ass
flavors at once yeah well I'm glad I was
able to humor you you humor you humored
humored all right well next up is uh
love love oh yeah yeah get him over
here so this is our turkey it's actually
Toof Fury so it's
tofu and uh it has a little bit of a
Twist I think the baby just kicked me
oh I'm sorry that's what I saying the
baby didn't laugh why does he have to
deal with this [__] I just felt a little
you could just chew it and get the the
flavor and spit it out if you wanted
to right fun all right well let's let's
get it on all right I'm not laughing I'm
going to go home and eat a normal meal
for sure and I'm going to feel happy and
good for sure don't remember remember
you made a new rule though I already ate
oh did you what what new rule did you
eat hell I did what new rule what rules
what rules
grills are we ready I think we're ready
take it away going start with a little
bit of a short one here hope it's
there's
audio don't you hold it all
right from the start I tasted the garlic
one here we go I know you don't really
don't want to try that up up
up
let's just hit that again that was
awesome isn't it so beautiful I love
that he's
Rush that is so funny all righty that
why do they have a mayonnaise in a bag
that's how they do it in Russia man you
know by the way you're not one to talk
in Israel they put milk in a bag yes but
not mayonnaise I've seen the Mayo in a
bag I think a few countries do it like
that Canada puts milk in a bag too
really I thought that was so interesting
hey compliment the file name love yeah
yeah thank you very
much very that was good yeah it's just a
little bit of a St the sound is powerful
a nice appetizer Sound by this one is a
little bit longer obviously so this is
one of my alltime favorite videos ever
and I always pull it out when I going to
make someone laugh and I think maybe
some of you guys have seen it but it's
definitely to get people in here not me
[Music]
all
the oh
[__] good
[Music]
[__] get the [__] out man P [__] what
[__] [__] bro me the hell out of here
[__] that I'm going to beat that [__]
ass I a get the [__] out of me you
little you little ugly
[__]
ra [__] go bu me I ain't pull me
t-shirt
bit Ain No Way Around Here a No Way
Around
money yeah [__] all
right jeez dude isn't that isn't that do
we know is there backstory does he did
he deserve it he's I think there are a
bunch of siblings living in a house or
something maybe a roommate franksters
they [__] with him all the time there's
multiple this poor guy is just getting
[__] with this bullying no they're all
friends you know it's just just funny
GI golly M it just kept going it's so
funny that was good that was good and it
was a slow consistent drip too it's so
slow but the funniest part I mean this
is not I don't want need to count this
but I don't know the first spray is just
so funny here
this is your second viewing so I think
this
[Music]
counts mouth
eyes oh [__] get the [__] out man push
[__] that where that [__] at I
heard I think you hear that it's so loud
in here it
was Ian you didn't hear me laugh did
you uh I didn't have it switched to you
but I'll just say yeah I did sorry there
it is that got a lot of people I have I
didn't laugh Dan C Sam Ela for sure okay
yeah else I'll cop to that all right all
right fine fine all right so this is my
I was close though all right do your ass
your ass in the comment SE Ian's the one
well I will say since it was a two-
minute long video if we're going to get
technical you get a second run on one of
those that's true we I said Thank you
Ian I I'll be honest I said this not
into I just want to show it again it's
fine thank you yeah I food you're going
to laugh at this one no no yeah you are
you might it's so
funny an
exclusive it
[Applause]
arrived oh my
God pumpkin
pie
just got a
warning not to be loud what can't be
loud for a little
bit next time I get
evicted they're buying every car in the
car
lot did you edit that
no oh that guy's good I like him that
was
tough I
hop let me see yeah well I I have one
last one if if that's go ahead yeah of
course of
course oh
no that's cheating I did work at a small
gaming store back
in 2006 2007 I am disabled uh recognized
by the state of Arkansas but also the
United States government there's that
now the downside of that is I am
extremely depressed so there's some
mental health issues that we bring to
the table and then
physically I have no references uh no
work history and no education and when
you Google my name you might see rumors
that I beat my ex-wife and I'm also a
pedophile should mention I'm also a
felon okay okay I've seen this so many
times if she can keep straight face yeah
we have no
excuse face when she she thinks he's
done and she's like he's just like no no
no I got a lot more oh we have just
begun all right all right so that's it
right so who's uh who's eating um oh my
God so you didn't get anybody on that
last one which means you get this yeah I
don't mind true you took a risk I mean
that one we've all seen so many times
yeah I just want to show all show like
the fun that one doesn't look that bad
yeah this is probably tofu turkey and it
looks marinated i' I've eaten these tof
Furys before and uh they they're fine
absolutely not now I did get two SLI
here it was the second one and it's even
in debate just do the one and did I
mention I have food poisoning you yeah I
think so I'm
recovering here we go yum yum Dan's
taking a
bite he's chewing big chews big heavy
chews bro he say we got a what the [__]
cam is not interested Sam you had they
take a bite eh even Sam
is you guys back to meet Dude what is
that love what's your take on that um
it's kind of like dog food but honestly
I think that's just the vegetarian ham
like already tast do you like it and
then there's something acidic on there
maybe yeah what is the you okay man Sam
is not able to chill she sucks you can't
swallow it Sam what's happening are you
trying stuck I'm stuck I was barely able
are you trying to chew are you trying to
just process what's happening take us
through swall it you swall you got it
nice job all right please what is that
what did I just eat dog food that's just
hickory smoked tofurky and citric acid
right just straight acid sick that's
what I made the WarHeads with oh oh
interesting oh my God it's like so sour
bizarre sour meat okay interesting
interesting all right um we just have ab
and Ela left so AB come on AB you have
not laugh okay so we're strategizing a
little bit here we have two more rounds
and we're out of dishes so we're
bringing back the garlic shrimp gelatin
for ab he's presenting so that means if
nobody laughs then AB has got to eat the
um entire thing cranberry sauce whole
eat it all so this so there's a lot on
the line AB how are you feeling
confident in your video selection I feel
like this is the rules are changing as
we go I don't it is a little bit but
that's okay that's why I am confident I
am confident though and I will say I
think they progressively get better in
my humble opinion okay well then then
then you have nothing to worry about
really should be fine right you get the
shot do you eat shrimp she's a que do
you eat shrimp uh yeah I do okay yeah
good is shrimp Hol um yeah well some
people Lena do people debate on shrimp I
know they debate on like some kind of no
generally it's Halal generally it's it
is yeah so you guys can eat shellfish
Shish people debate shellfish I mean
crab and stuff no oh okay there's been
debate about that but like my parents
are very like uh like they they follow
Halal and we've shrimp has always been
okay is shrimp not a shell to Jewish
people don't eat shrimp right I don't
think so but shrimp isn't a shellfish I
think it's kind of a shellfish but it's
right kind
of all right so anyway a there's a lot
on the line here AB so hopefully they're
funny eh yeah here we go you got this
Spiderman isy all right no zip
it they always try not to you said no
commentary
oh this this Spider-Man
[Music]
compilation oh my God
[Applause]
no w
Peter
[Applause]
Parker not funny did
laugh but you did laugh I didn't laugh
that was so good I was shocked I didn't
hear any laugh well Ian you're the one I
mean did anyone laugh I mean I'm cutting
around I I didn't see a laugh but did
anyone at the table see a laugh I I
don't know I did I see okay what I did
was exclaimed a little bit when I
realized that he was drowning in the
pool I heard that that's not a laugh no
he that was more of a no it was a he's
concerned it was a and I've seen that
clip too the guy's dying he's after it
have a heart damn it I don't know I mean
listen I like Spider-Man list did you
edit those together yeah I did you know
it's quite a compilation well done
that's an original fail army I've seen
some yeah I slipped in one that they we
left that on the show once it was the
accordion yeah the accordion one which
is I think that is the top number I
think you'd get me if the music wasn't
there maybe here's the thing Dan would
be honest yeah Dan's laughed and may we
all have been genuine like when I
realized what was happening in the pool
I was shocked and I'm not just saying
this because I want you to eat this I
think it's interesting if we keep
going well listen it's already done it's
done all we have to do is get through
one I'm telling you when we play the
tape you're you're going to hear it okay
if you say so I'm willing to take I will
say I did like the a Peter Parker sorry
that's a good one wait what are you what
are you saying when we play the tape
we'll hear the laugh I'm saying the
laugh before the oh you want to play it
back that's cool
I mean I'm gonna end up eating either
way so whatever yeah all right if you
want to wait for the T you have the
right to if keep contesting dance dance
uh sure yeah no if you're we should keep
going regardless this show has Integrity
yeah absolutely this is not like all
these other Bullit
serious now that one was just uh oh [__]
what the [__] AB do you eat food with
because sometimes food if you cook
garlic into it it's like it kind of
disappears when you cook it a lot no he
doesn't like garlic at all if there's
any garlic I'll eat garlic I just if I'm
like alone at home it's super late I'm
not seeing nobody I don't want garlic
breath I don't want to be walking around
is that why you hate it cuz it makes
your breath stink that's part of it yeah
oh I hate this if you're at home by
yourself you'll eat garlic french
fries yeah what well then you don't hate
garlic but you won't cook garlic you
won't cook with I want the house he
doesn't want the place smelling
yeah you like garlic yeah so I'm not oh
oh interesting a whole different did you
know that yeah he's very peculiar but
yeah he peul he's a weird guy he is a
weird guy sweet way to moving on to
video two first one was just an
appetizer okay I don't even like the
first one uh oh New Cairo just dropped
oh boy oh
no nice show them M there we
go
nice get him up
[Music]
there P good money for
this catch of the
[Laughter]
day he just knock a cork out of him what
was
that
[Applause]
[Music]
here holy
[__] that's him making that sound for
sure
[Applause]
oh my God that was hilarious that was so
hard yeah that was hard I heard some
laughs oh my God squealing that was got
me yeah you crazy I have to admit that
it wasn't him it wasn't it was Brian
Cranston in a Breaking Bad blooper did
you edit that in yeah okay
you got nose exhale so that I ra i oh
you got yeah oh [__] okay Cam can you
lean forward too I couldn't see you on
the camera okay I can't see cuz I'm
trying to stay low I don't know if
that's helpful or not I couldn't te on
that one but uh I can see him what got
me actually was uh your comment about it
being Catch of the Day you got did that
get anyone else as a as a referee here
Dan laughed but then he immediately
pointed at Ethan and said you're comment
yeah how does that uh that's
true that doesn't count laugh you could
just say I laughed it's fine laugh laugh
is the laugh all right ready for my
final video guys yeah let's not laugh
here oh this is an original maybe
creative star screaming goes with
everything
okay
[__] okay [__] work
well oh
no
[__] [__] you [__]
[__] now that's comedy okay wow m
very
good good I mean I like what you did
definitely a good good good really good
it's like good creation all is it just
you and me or do you get anybody else Mr
Cameron and Lena oh and Lena okay okay
are we all served up we are you got this
thank you
I you know just give it a you don't even
have to do the shrimp just hit the jello
you know I'm trying to
get he's really he's scared the garlic
although he liking makes me so scared
also found out he likes garlic right did
try um there is a little bit shrim in
here I got I made sure to get like some
of the the notes of it okay look I don't
see I I don't see any
shrimp we do it I can't I can't [__]
with the shrimp yeah okay oh that's
right all right so cam have you tried
the the toe FY yeah unfortunately to My
Le your second one yeah right here we go
yeah Cheers Cheers everybody lenie have
you tried that one no and then AB who's
we're all watching that's a big bite you
don't have to do it oh God ay took a big
bite nope oh boying really oh he's back
we're so back that quickly there was a
it's barely in his mouth bad yeah he got
wow it's really nasty it's bad yeah no
thank you oh gosh I'm
shocked there you go how does it
function so fast hiss out yeah yeah it's
got to be oh my God Big Bite he didn't
have to take that big of a bite but I
appreciate his
dedication solding send yeah I
appreciate that there was a big ass bite
yeah oh my God but you good over there
damn did you blow
chunks no but so it wasn't just the
jello there was like breakfast came up
with it
something he said are you okay yeah are
you yeah of course she's asking because
you seem to have gotten over your puking
phobia I have I've definitely lessened
since working here
fantastic anyone else have any phobias
they want help getting over a great Z we
can I can do a lot of work for you you
see how you see how she's do tried that
in occupational therapy did not go well
did you really yeah with birds
specifically when I was like five six
years years old I was in occupational
therapy you were too young then threw me
they try to expose you to birds yeah we
went to a park in enino and pigeons like
from home alone too you know [__] up
I'm so sorry what they what did they do
to you they gave me some
crackers feed the
[__] oh no did the pigeons like mess
with you or like run at you the fear of
that and the fluttering oh okay the
deasis you never know with those birds
hate birds but do you think would you
trust me to help you uh no absolutely
not absolutely not man I just feel like
it really help you God bless you but no
not a shot now not the client's Klein
water stuff either that that's I feel
like that you've kind of yeah I've
accepted it you think we could work on
that maybe well we I mean I did exposure
therapy at the [__]
uh I feel like that did kind of work
dead you're
alive I know someone that heard it and
had some recently okay recently recently
had a really bad thing hold on we have a
lot of we all hear lots of things all
the time no no no no no this is like you
can but you sat in that haunted bathroom
and sang it with us I didn't have a
choice but okay but my point is you're
still alive you're doing well barely
yeah that is true you know but we can't
put that on Credence plus I it was
pitched down so it wasn't full effect oh
interesting that's some weird [__]
[__] right there man so in your mind you
think because it wasn't play it at its
normal uhac pitch that it was less
impactful you in in the intrusive
thought brain of Zachary bernon yes mean
that does make sense interesting
interesting okay wait Ethan do you have
any irrational fear
years
eggs eggs after days I mean I don't like
I don't know if they call them
irrational I don't like spiders I don't
like want a spider on me I'm with you on
the spider thing I don't think it's
irrational don't [__] with spiders it's
very rational yeah the area I grew up in
we had spiders bite yeah exactly we had
black widow but other ones toow and uh
kill you yeah thankfully never got bit
by a black widow but I did get spider
bites all the time growing up and it
yeah me too Woodland Hills [__]
yes and see I feel like it instilled
like you said a very rational fear of
spiders I've seen Black Widow so many
times in my yard even where we live now
I saw him in our yard Shredder was like
sniffing at it I would cry if I saw any
scary I had one on my hand a couple
months ago what where what um I was at
my friend's place and they I threw a a
like collapsed box away outside and I
needed it so I went back out to get it
and when I picked it up I was putting
the box together and it was just like
like on my hand and I screamed and I'd
like no nope nope no nope nope nope oh
my God I don't think they're very
aggressive spiders I'm terrified of
roaches that's
likees Ian can confirm roaches are
that's I guess more irrational CU
they're not like dangerous they're just
really gross they're too fast Ally loves
spiders like actually actively likes
them and like she's like oh they're so
cute or whatever but she's terrified of
roaches I'm like you got it all
backwards roaches they're gross but like
they don't do anything you know what I
mean no they're harmless hurt they're V
they're gross fast like a creepy
craw similar to the birds with fling do
I have a I don't know that makes sense I
don't think mine is
Heights like if you go to like the top
of a building at like the observation
deck out even in our apartment building
on our porch like I get uneasy still by
the by The Edge H yeah on our
balcony that's like halfway between
irrational and rational because
obviously you can get very hurt from
Heights so that seems rational to be
afraid of falling from
Heights uh but I guess if if it's like
freaking you out when you're there's no
possibility of that even happening and
then it starts to dip into Birds is a
good old one though that's Bird good
that's good oh that's good stuff does
anyone else have phobias do you have one
just Heights really yeah vom vom vom
right
it used to be driving but now I take the
110 to work there it is
baby that's like driving on X I got I'm
so proud of Cameron for doing that and
driving he's a [__] Pro
now yeah thank you thank you it was just
it was just because when I was a kid I
got in a bad accident so it it freaked
me out of getting behind the wheel so
sure I'm glad you got up through that
rational fear well I what everyone does
you have a you hate cockroaches yeah I
think that's probably mine mhm but I'm I
never wanted us to even have this
conversation cuz I'm afraid of
people KN that yeah you don't even want
toit that I think everyone knows that
I'm calling the Cockroach guy yeah now
anyone else want to confess yeah on
camera love vegetables I mean that's not
really a fear it's just grow makes me
puke no that would't freak me out
Godfather I'm deathly scared of like
public speaking and yeah [__] like that
yeah do it all the time I know yeah it's
weird but that's normal everyone hates
that right yeah but I I'm like insanely
scared of it but dude I brought you to
party I brought you to parties into like
the life of the party nobody knows you
and I don't think I'm a social butterfly
I
think not that I know of I mean would
you tell me if you did
yeah to hell I mean that's that that's
just that
being if you're going to hell you do I
don't think you'll find an Arab kid who
doesn't so you I know you you guys
aren't like theout obviously right you
guys are fairly uh yeah our parents are
both pretty old school both of our
parents we would like to be more not
like super religious but I like I don't
pray always pray five times a day but I
tried my best to oh you do yeah oh there
you go and do you I don't know how yeah
I I've tried to learn but it's tough
because you're only supposed to do in
Arabic but I don't speak Arabic so okay
it's tough for me to remember and so
hell is a thing that you how often do
you think about hell when I was younger
a lot more like I was so scared one time
I even told my aunt and I'm so thankful
to this Aunt because she's the one who
taught me how to pray but at the same
time she scared me so much and I was
like if this is what the hell is and
this is what's waiting for me like I
wish I wasn't even born like I'd rather
not be born and then or than to live and
and have to suffer that that after so
E's Lise it was so weird to me that she
didn't like talk me out of that or
anything she's just like yeah that's how
it is like okay okay there you go yeah
so do you still think about hell
frequently not as much as I used to it
you really traumatized me as a kid but
not so much anymore and you a yeah a
couple times a day but it's just Roman
Empire it's weird it's not like I'm like
in constant religious fear but I don't
know I guess the good part of it is like
that's where I feel like I'm not
judgmental towards people because of
that like because I I'm like was so
scarred by being judged by my own family
members and being told I'm going to hell
it makes me very like open-minded to
people like I just want everybody to not
constantly be afraid of something good
America that's good that's beautiful
yeah well
said fearing fearing hell never hurt
anybody a little fear of God right
yeah the thing is a lot of like Middle
Eastern kids at least in our hometown
Dearborn they think they're going to
hell already so they're like [__] it
let's let's go that's my
mentality that's pretty that's pretty
not like a cool rock and roll though
hell Z like a Satan like Skinner and
[__] you know yeah not that no like
riding a motorcycle with a leather
jacket and like a skull head not that
kind of and when you were a kid what did
you think hell was when you were like
had that revelation of like wish I was
never born um well just like they tell
you about things that if you don't
follow by certain rules and what happens
like for example I don't wear the head
scarf so for every piece of hair is a
year of hell time yeah and which isn't
true I don't think it's just these are
stories that like I hear from relatives
or um if I'm not praying five times a
day I'll have to make the all of those
up in hell and and like do it on boiling
water like just crazy stories like that
so
intense wow like
that can I ask why you're holding the
spoon like
that SC intimidating you tell you later
that's how my aunt looked when she told
me I'm going to hell all right Ela
you're the last one I last one and so it
looks like I can't help but notice that
the mashed potatoes have made their way
back out
here
peppermint I mean it could also be the
mac and cheese but I know Ethan Ethan
hasn't tried the potatoes yet right I
didn't try the mac and cheese either the
mac and cheese had the blue cheese which
Ela can't have so I think this one makes
more sense true true all right all right
let's do it so I will say it was very
hard I don't I'm not online really
except watching the podcast so I don't
have any like video funny videos on hand
uh so I just did like Instagram reals so
that's fine it's pretty dumb we like I
love reals
mhm okay so first one
and then it's five but they're super
short like okay that
works all
right Earth is clearly place it
says I
myve that
right
Jesus
[__] hey we Lo out we out
damn
[__] youb ass
[__] I Instagram car is upside
down
trying to get a look place this ISRO all
right there a lot going on in this video
but I just got one question yeah you
know what I'm saying at the gas station
where that white dude come
from awesome
wow wait can I watch hell out of me dude
I will say Instagram reals I see people
die [__] is so much crazier than TI goed
compared to Tik Tok I agree dude we can
lose Tik Tok we have Instagram can I
call
pedoph all means I let out so many like
during that that at the end I was just
like I'm going to go for it yeah wait I
want to hear I want to see his comment
at the end he was like where did this
white guy come from that was what I was
to wait which white guy we got to
rewatch watch let's watch it again this
was really a good
video I mean I
wasis the woman who screaming at the
end
okay so he was trying to get her out of
the car [__] go back I want to see him
get dragged again hey move move move
move
ready he just spawned there oh
[__] hey move move move ready oh that
was him walking off there then yeah he's
just going home yeah everyone was like
she the whole truck next time you look
the car is just upside down how happen
What
doing got
one I
got all right this a lot going on in
this video but I just got one question
at the gas station where that white dude
come from yeah wow okay that was really
good side note can we show all
that I mean nothing happened to him you
see him was hurt everyone fine and she
was fine at the end too everyone's fine
everyone's happy everyone's fine I did
not I you think that was the best one
out of my videos okay starting out with
a banger there yeah I wanted to if
somebody was going to laugh I wanted you
guys to do it in the
beginning right next one great I got the
peppermint potatoes
again Shadow relax relax shadow shadow
relax
[Music]
Shadow what wait play that again was
this fake or real I wonder I think that
this guy actually does this to people
she threw her food on the ground or what
happened I've seen this guy a bunch
before Oh you have
yeah I'll tell you what nobody walks
with their food like
[Music]
that wait go back go back look how she's
holding her food who who walks around
with her whole ass like meal out like
that
also also looking
down where the camera's right front of
them right right right didn't even think
about that I also don't feel like he
would have touched her with the thing
unless he like knew her yeah that's
pretty all right this is
[Music]
um this my little story is that this is
Ethan took a flight this is the first
video from on board the Delta Airlines
flight that had to be turned around
because of a passenger's explosive
diarrhea here is the message from on
board the plane just a biohazard issue
you know we had a pastor had diarrhea
all the way through the airplane so they
want us to come back to Atlanta what
somebody [__] all in the plane looks
like it oh that is a
biohazard you can see this is the first
video from on board the Delta Airlines
flight that be turned around because of
a passenger's explosive diarrhea here is
the message from on board the plane is
that a terrorist
attack diary all the way through the
airplane so they want us to come back to
Atlanta wow man [__] out of Atlanta holy
[__] is right yeah wow I'm really
appreciating how Joker brain her videos
are
though some of the biggest most [__]
up ones that first one was definitely
the most [__] up one we saw
today yeah all they get dumber and
dumber I apologize dumber and dumber is
okay
what but if I walk normally
watch Wait
seriously once more once more it was
short that's funny that was what I was
thinking too this wasn't arise any
suspicion but if I walk normally
watch
those guys are funny as hell holy [__]
all
right holy [__] man all right what is my
last one I don't okay last one all right
yeah one
more I was too excited to
eat I've seen this
one oh oh my
God I love that dog so much so much like
Shredder would do play that again I love
one it up here full screen that person
is so
F
oh I love
thater on
oh so cute very nice very nice that was
a laugh I did I laughed okay where's
your
plate get some taters for you got you my
PL has like spit very good Ela those
were great vids very good for someone
who's not on the internet yeah I felt so
bad I thought they were all CRA yeah
before the show started you were like
I'm going to be happy if I just get a
smile out of people but oh Jesus Christ
unhinged nasty nasty as [__] I guess so
I only have a wi just with the end so
you can uh you can go for
it oh yeah smell
bro all right just doing it
quick
oh oh poor Dan that's all right here
okay here I go this is is this big
enough no no no you're freak putting it
in your
hand okay wooden spoon that's big that's
too big fine no gravy what do you
want eat
it eat it you can do it there you
go that just cured your food poisoning
right
there your mint's good for an upset
stomach grumbling it cancels out the the
garlic smells good
now mint's good for an upside T what do
you think look like Ethan's crying
there's like a glimmer on his lower lid
like from where I'm
sitting sweat on his brow wow you're
letting it linger too long it's worse
the longer you wait you got to just like
just slam it down drink some sus Su it
up it up it up it up it up it up take it
like a
pill
anyway all
[Applause]
right why is that combo so foul I don't
know what it is so wrong about it I
don't know did you try that Sam I tried
it last year when I made it yeah you
want to try it again this year I'm cool
good it's the same it's crushed candy
canes so everybody ate everybody did it
AB you puked it's been a whole full year
the whole thing did the whole the full
monty I
believe
is not going to oh yeah Ian get out here
Dan can you switch and we'll have Ian do
aish BG out here a potluck po look
time what that's right poor then look at
his plat I know that's a full plate he
was married today he was a I was not
laughing today lots of Mirth happening
in I rolled up some green bean inside of
this great presentation it that could be
for Ian yeah that's a good one yeah
[Music]
yeah Sam cut make him a
special stop stop
plotting no this is good you're the one
that's like this is easy work for me I
didn't say that you said that make sure
that I thought the arrangement was outd
e it with a that was our
original you still can we were going to
he was trying to do this romantic arm
wait hold on you did say that I'll do it
from my from my shake my my uh what what
we call ourselves Tremor Brothers shaky
hand Bros yeah shaky hand Bron sounds
like a
website the bang
bro so Sam is creating a special
cocktail for Ian Ian what do you think
lot of scooping happening back there at
that
beauty Dan he laughed a lot yeah yeah he
had a good day anything he's a laugher
that's what I admire about him me too
can you do me a fav as we prepare can we
go back and watch my one video again oh
yeah because it was the first one there
was no primer I'm happy that it did get
some laughter but I'm curious to revisit
it and
see
um if it still hits the Baba buoy the
overlays of you doing Baba buy guys you
liked it
yeah damn it godamn
it the original video is so funny you
like that one yeah Baba I was cringing
when I went watch that this was
like Baba Bo bua bu
bua it's almost
broken all right I guess was okay pretty
good
Dam dam next year I'll bring
some some original more original heat so
what do we got uh
Ian where ab's PL oh so you are doing
this
yeah was your idea solidarity iing solid
just here's Lena if you want to put on
that Lena pl's pretty I mean one [__]
thing though I can't do all that why is
there so much food here I gave you one
Thanksgiving man oh wow you got a whole
plate Thanksgiving you just take a bite
in quick succession I can really smell
it
all
yeah okay what do I do here just dig in
brother Thanksgiving help yourself start
there Ian he says this is light work
let's see let's see what the hum garbage
proposal can do oh he's
taking sh are in here
wow yeah yeah yeah yeah where's the
camera yeah oh I love what I'm seeing
Ian this is very good this is very
impressive that's gonna be such
a yeah okay nice we got the jello we got
the pie we got it's it's all
yeah love it we love it and put it wrap
it in some no dude you're going to
regret that you're going to regret that
no he's not's this man has ate a whole
ass s strowman fish God [__] Legend
dude hold on hold on you
got bring that bring that we need the
close-ups yeah yeah keep it
going Happy Thanksgiving from Ian to
yours I'm so thankful
oh D what a beast wow dud what a beast
Ian is UN containable he meant what he
said oh but he's he's struggling
actually with it Ian you have to look
for the almost I can't tell he looks
like he's struggling more than the S
stromman is this harder than
sowman oh my goodness he is really
struggling I bet that ham alone is so oh
no oh yeah that that's he is really
that's sour
turkey it's a bite that's a good man
there that's a good man well cats are
going to love it how's it going over
there Ian there's a lot in your mouth
still a lot of food yeah you have have
some mac and
cheese what are you thankful this year
Ian I wish I had some gamer Subs to wash
this down you need some you need a
beverage shout
out we'll work on that someone's working
on that right now no I got it it's just
very s
yeah that's the the
toy did you try the also the mac and
cheese Sam no he didn't get it on the
that on the spoon you didn't try the oh
God all right wow
dude wow you weren't kidding man you
really can kick a little wet little tear
forming on the cor my eye and how does
that compare to the S stromman you know
I just admire Sam's cooking so much
she's so talented I always appreciate
her cooking you know so that would
wouldn't that mean that it was her
objective was for it to be gross so then
that's saying it's worse than the S
struming cuz that would be the
compliment
right it's not nothing beats
the that is horrible yeah and I noticed
you didn't try the mac and cheese mac
and cheese is brought up no I think you
just said you admire her cooking she the
one
how that does not look like mac and
cheese that is unique
this hit it Careful by far the grossest
one he took big he took a big bite he's
chewing it is a monster man this guy can
do the impossible this is blue cheese
yeah yes I love blue
cheese really he loves it
El good that's what thanksgiving's all
about it's a Thanksgiving year you bring
that went back okay maybe maybe this
Thursday I know to the table y well
that's everything huh well thank you
guys uh for for joining us this year
thank you to all the crew for being here
having fun and participating and eating
lots of gross stuff than you thank you
hope you guys all have a fantastic
Thanksgiving this is pre-recorded on
Tuesday and I'm wishing you guys a Happy
Thanksgiving even though I'll see you
guys tomorrow yep right Happy
Thanksgiving to
you um so have a great weekend enjoy the
holiday with your family and uh lots of
love over here from the A Street podcast
what's going on Ian you okay like burp
oh I got the hiccups a little bit are
you okay he's I'm okay I just what do
you have fart ass
M egg
burps
septic yes that's really nice of you all
right every everybody see you on uh
Monday have a great beautiful happy
family filled uh weekend and if you
don't have family or friends then then
[__]
them it's definitely not your fault it's
what these Instagram reals doing to
you they'll be fine they send me orus as
you call right a man of many orphans
it's not your fault it's their fault I'm
sure of it they suck they're scumbags
[__] them all all right guys see you on
day